the reason I designed this mass was
really just to experience synesthesia
for myself that was it it actually
worked the first time I put it on that
never happens so I think thank the maker
gods for that so how does synesthesia
actually work people with synesthesia
have multiple areas of the brain
activated by a single stimulus so for
example for a synesthete who associates
colors with smells when they see the
color red the area of the brain
associated with sight might be activated
but so would the area of the brain
associated with smell the senses and
concepts that can overlap are widely
diverse they include smells numbers
taste
music days of the week colored shapes
and even pain the first time I
encountered it was actually a friend his
wife has it and for her her synesthesia
is numbers and colors and that just
sounds beautiful to me to see it in math
to see math is beautiful as a Monet
painting come on I mean I think it
changed the way you interact and
perceive the world how is x-mass able to
mimic this condition he wears a color
sensor on his finger it's something that
detects the amount of red green and blue
in anything is pointed at this Sansa
connects to a series of tubes containing
scented oils when it passes over blue he
smells lavender he passes it over red he
smells grapefruit and when he passes
over green
he smells pine the experience of wearing
this device was it's hard to describe
because you're experiencing a world that
no one else is at that moment when I
brought it outside and I'm wandering
down the pier and most people are
smelling the ocean the experience you're
having at that moment is different than
everyone else around you it's difficult
to describe to other people and I feel
lucky to have experienced it biophysical
hacking I love it